one thing
you mentioned he's probably gonna push
my buttons
it's a good place to ask a question
about anger so i'll probably get pissed
off at him at some point
i'm guessing and
do you have thoughts from a scientific
perspective
or also just the personal philosophical
perspective about the role of anger and
all of this in
in managing alertness performance
i think about this a lot because there's
so much out there about how important it
is to do things from a place of love
you know i tweet about it all the time
and i think and
love is powerful right you know it is
interesting that autonomic arousal
alertness let's just make use simple
language alertness
physiologically looks identical for
love and excitement as it does for
anger and frustration and wanting to
defeat your opponent or whoever that
opponent happens to be
they're identical except that the love
component does
tend to be associated with the release
of neurochemicals of the serotonin and
dopamine type
that do have this replenishment
component i don't think one wants to be
in
constant anger and friction but
i mean i'll come clean a bit there's
been portions of my career where some of
my best work my extra two hours my
ability to nail
a really hard deadline or problem has
come from
not wanting to get out competed or from
wanting to
prove something these days i
i don't i'm not oriented from that place
toward my work quite as often but i
think we should be really honest anger
is
powerful provided it's channeled it's
very very powerful and it can give you
a ton of fuel and gas to
push when otherwise you'd tap yeah
joe rogan has aside from being a fan of
his
has been an inspiration to sort of be to
have a kind of
loving view on the world in the way you
approach the world
to me so i've tended to want to approach
the world that way but in the same way
david goggins has been an inspiration to
like
uh yeah be angry at stuff and
use it as fuel like he almost uh
conjures up artificial demons in his
mind just so he can fight them
i you know but at the same time i tried
that because i did a challenge in the
summer
of a world for 30 days i was doing a lot
of push-ups and
it was uh over time it was
counterproductive for me
like i found that it was easier to just
like the roller coaster that the
emotional
like being angry at stuff takes you can
also be exhausting
oh absolutely and it can take you down
like the
the ups of it are good but the downs are
bad
and what i found is better to get to use
it as a boost every once in a while but
mostly to get
lost in the you're talking about the
breath work that
like getting lost in the ritual of it
like that the be
like that as opposed to going on the big
roller coasters of emotion
you